it may very well be  that salman khan  becomes the most important educator in  the entire world oh it's great to be  here and i like the the low expectations  we get these great headlines because  people like the story  you know the messiah of math  one one i liked in particular was the  math of khan  when we let these students work at their  own pace yeah right in the beginning  there were this group of kids that just  raced ahead and you'd say oh those are  the gifted kids and but what we see is  if you let this group over here  work at their own pace and they were  able to fill in all those gaps and  really get mastery at them that same kid  that you thought was weak six months ago  is now the best student in the class and  we're seeing that over and over again  the book is the the one world school  house and you're going to do a google  hangout for us on the 17th right that's  right  you